the whole coming up my baby father
[ __ ] that doesn't make me feel any
better
cardi B is coming to offsets defense
after he made a grand gesture to win her
back grand is right offset will stop at
nothing to save his marriage with car D
you're right but while car D seems
unimpressed she is taking the high road
after offset interrupted her show to
apologize take a look on Saturday offset
crash car D set at rolling loud in LA
with a romantic gesture he pulled a
3-piece sign made of roses that read
take me back okay so is this really
sincere I watched the video car D space
said a lot she seemed very unimpressed I
think she's still hurt that's the thing
I think you know love makes you do crazy
things I'm all for a grand gesture but
do not interrupt me at my place of work
not into that
oh no and that goes for all occupations
in place yes okay so she has also made
it clear that she's not taking him back
but I would like to have them work on
co-parenting and it seems like it's
going in that direction I know you're
right she has taken a complete high road
on this she's just like leave him alone
you know we're working on things kind of
publicly not as privately as I would
have liked yeah we are working on things
later the migos rapper took to Twitter
explaining why he apologized in front of
a large crowd writing all of my wrongs
have been made public I figure it's only
right that my apologies are made public
to I don't know it might take time to
get a divorce and I'm gonna always have
a lot of love for him because he is my
daughter's father
one thing that was public is when cardi
announced that they were calling it
quits she explained how they grew out of
love and she tried to work things out
what off said despite those numerous
cheating allegations and offside also
failed to make things right with his
estranged wife in a lengthy video
apology on his birthday I was partaking
of activity that I should've been taking
in and I apologized you know I'm saying
breaking your heart breaking that
promise
breaking God's promise and being a
selfish
mr. buzzby okay so after offsets onstage
antics fans literally ripped him online
with tons of hateful comments yeah and
this prompted cardi to speak out on
Instagram live to be gentler with the
way that they handle him I just don't
like that bashing online thing just
earlier you just saw how Pete Davidson
was talking about he don't even want to
be on this earth because mad people be
coming to him every single day I
wouldn't want my baby father gonna have
that feeling because of millions of
people be bashing him every day
that's a nasty feeling and I wouldn't
want that I think cardi has a point it's
really important to discuss mental
health right now and this is her baby's
father as she said time and time again
this is a family while he's you know
done things in the past I think cardi
has a point I'm glad she's speaking out
yeah and she's made it very clear that
her number one priority is culture at
the end of the day their relationship I
think she just kind of wants to put his
aside at the moment and focus on the
parenting aspect of their relationship
which they should and then that brings
the question should we focus on
co-parenting do they just need
counseling to fix their marriage some
time apart what do you think I don't
know it's one of those things where like
I know that's private and we shouldn't
weigh in but also this is very public so
Val we can't help but weigh in I don't
know no but we do want to know how you
guys feel about offset gesture be sure
to subscribe to all things et until next
time I'm at Kourtney underscore teza
know and I'm a - Carlsen